no matter how good we are we can still
be better
you can always be better people like me
i was born in a very poor family
i never got a great education whatever
you focus on
whatever gets your attention gets
results want to be happy build a life
not just a business
hey it's evancar michael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the difference
between
the rich and the poor mindset
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one use negative feedback to grow
with jeff bezos you shop on amazon
and uh if you have something the service
you don't like
yeah so do you just pick up the phone
call your team of 700 000 people
and tell them i don't like this change
this or you know what i do
so um i don't do this it doesn't happen
that often but if i get a delivery that
i don't like maybe i don't like when
it's packaged or something
we have regular meetings of the senior
executive team
and i bring the box to the meeting and
when i walk in i haven't done this in a
while it's been a while but when i
bring in a box everybody in the room is
like oh no he's bringing in a box
because it's always some problem but
really the way i get feedback
is to is primarily from my email address
is very well known and i keep it well
known and i get
hundreds and hundreds of emails every
day from customers
and they always have something
interesting to say when something goes
wrong
because we have hundreds of millions of
customers around the world and no matter
how good we are
we can still be better you can always be
better
customers have a divine discontent and
they teach you if you listen to
customers
so we watch for that and we see patterns
and we can find places where it's not
working
something's going wrong and that's
really how i get the feedback
is from customer input and often you
know
in all caps angry you ruined my child's
birthday because the gift didn't show up
on time
and we take that and what you really
want to do
is you take that it's an anecdote it's a
single example
but you need to find the root cause what
went wrong
deep inside the system how did this
happen because then you can fix it for
everyone
so that particular problem will never
happen again you don't just
fix the symptom you have to fix the root
cause and that's been the secret to our
operational success for 20 years
rule number two spend your time wisely
with mark zuckerberg
do you split your time on the regular
between
facebook instagram uh oculus
whatsapp or is it sort of every day has
a little bit of everything
yeah i definitely split my time a bit
more because there are just so many
pieces at this point that
if i were trying to tune into everything
every day then
it would just be too much context
switching so as a matter of fact what i
try to do is like have a theme
for a week and you know maybe usually i
can't get away with just one
theme but i'll try to do two or three
things in a week
and have most of my time be focused on
on kind of nailing that and doing a good
job at that then of course different
things come up i'm talking to people
throughout the day
but you know we have really good people
running each of the apps you know it
works well as a team and and that that
allows me to focus on
on you know some of the stuff that i
think is the most important
and and whatever is coming out that that
that um that i need to deal with
rule number three know what you really
want with dean graziosi
one of them is people that i mean
whatever you focus on
whatever gets your attention gets
results if you're listening right now
and you're
you're in great shape it means your body
is getting attention you're eating the
right food you're working out
if your company's doing amazing you have
focus
attention and hunger i mean that's
that's a great one too is you have
hunger
for that business you have hunger to be
in great shape if you have a romantic
passionate love and relationship for 15
years
it gets your focus it gets your
attention you don't ignore it so the one
thing that i've seen
is if you think of all the habits
someone can have is someone who's
successful in every way
or in a lot of ways not just wealthy but
overweight and unhealthy you know you
know overweight and healthy
is they really know what's important
and they say no to all the things that
complicate that so i don't want to go
down this too far but
i make myself a not to do list all the
time
louis and i obsess on knowing what i
really want
most times people that are living with
suffering or stress or worry most of
their life is focused on what they don't
want
i don't want this employee to be
annoying anymore i don't want this to
happen i don't want this president
anymore i don't i don't i don't
and they don't have enough of knowing
when crystal clear clarity where it is
they want to go so you ask me one thing
in common
the most successful people i know if you
got them in an elevator and say hey man
what's the next year your life look like
bam bam you know this from all your
interviews oh we're doing this we're
starting this new company we're doing
this
you ask somebody who's struggling or not
happy they'll tell you what they don't
want even if you
ask them and anybody listening you could
do this ask somebody
who's not doing well what they want out
of life and they'll tell you what they
don't want they go you know what i don't
want this damn job anymore
even though you ask them what they want
so i think that's someone who's not
doing well
not doing well so i really believe that
i don't want to be broke i don't want to
be in this relationship i don't want to
be in this
ass relationship she doesn't give me
hope or he doesn't listen to me
right i don't want to be in this job
where everybody takes him it's like but
what do you really want
man i just don't want to worry about
money anymore it's like wow
but ask somebody who's successful in a
lot of areas your life like oh man
i want to get my new company off the
ground i want to get in better shape
like they know where it is they want to
go so i would say
they can figure out okay what are the
steps to getting there right how do i do
that right so
i guess the longer answer to a short
question because you asked for three is
if you really know where you want you
point your ship in that direction
and successful people start saying no to
all the things that don't
serve them going in that direction if it
doesn't serve god it doesn't serve
a better a bigger better version of you
it doesn't serve more income a better
relationship
doesn't serve your health successful
people know how to say i'm not doing it
or someone talks in the life you're gone
like they're not eating the sugar
they're not drinking they're not doing
those things and and literally when you
do that in all areas life where do i
want to go with my health okay anything
that doesn't serve that
i'm not doing it where do i want to go
my income okay i'm going to focus on
that i'm going to point my ship in that
direction
if it doesn't match i'm throwing it away
where do i want with my intimacy and my
passion like
figure out read the books gain the
capability so what's up man it's good to
see you i i'd see you all over the place
i see you hustling
i see your impact in lives doing amazing
stuff on youtube
i want to share whatever works for you
know you're following my following today
but i want to share dude your book built
to serve
you are built to serve there's a
difference when
you know this is i've been an
entrepreneur for entrepreneur for over
30 years i've been in the self-education
industry for 24.
can't even seem it doesn't even seem
possible but there's a lot of people
that
when you kind of meet your heroes or you
meet the people behind the book
a habits book a built to serve book a
time management it's like you beat you
meet the guy with the time management
book and he's late getting on stage and
stressed out of his mind in the green
room
like there's no congruency is what i
want to say and before we chat today i
just want to honor you
and give you congruency this what you
wrote in this book is really who you are
man
you are built to serve you reach out to
my team all the time and
want to help with youtube and tell us
what we're doing wrong and it's not
you're
not doing it because of finances you're
not doing it because you're trying to
get an edge you're doing it just because
this is who you are man so i love seeing
you out there i love seeing you grow i
love seeing the impact you're making
cool man appreciate it i'm still working
on accepting compliments so
um i'll just say thank you then i'm
gonna keep doing it through this entire
thing to make you feel uncomfortable oh
great classic dean all right cool well
you know what also in that story um
you know you've been really helpful in
getting that book out i remember when i
came to puerto rico
and uh was trying to get feedback on
pre-launch
you and brendan burchard took time
backstage
while you're doing your big event people
paid all this money to come there and
you took time
over lunch for 40 minutes to do a deep
dive
on my strategy and just super grateful
that you guys did that and
you hooked me up with your warehouse and
you know a whole bunch of things that
dean's a big reason why the book is has
uh uh
just a little piece man just what's up
everybody i see the highs so listen
um appreciate everybody i see all the
cool comments coming in so how can we
deliver some value today how do we help
out besides
um i do gotta plug this like if you
didn't check out
uh evan's built to serve you should
check it out um the truth is
i'm not all the way done i freaking love
it my biggest problem is every book i
read evan i listen
i i have such a hard time reading i
still have dyslexia
it still doesn't stick so it's taking me
longer but when i actually read a book
it sticks so i highly recommend it and
uh
it's just you it's like it's it's having
a 200 page conversation with you which
is
which is always cool cool man appreciate
it well we also i also have an audiobook
version i read it myself
so there's always oh dude please send
that to me
rule number four think long term with
dan lok
to become successful i think the very
first thing you have to
understand is this that successful
people we think
very differently from the rest of the
society
because most of the society the general
public
they are not successful so the way that
we think the way that we view things
are very very different and today i want
to share with you just some of the
distinctions some of the powerful
distinctions that how incredibly
successful people think
so you can start today making some
new decisions that's the purpose now i
could probably spend
a couple hours just talking about all
the little distinctions but today i want
to give you three major ones
here's the very very first one long time
ago i've had the
fortune to have a lot to have lunch
with one of the most successful one of
the wealthiest
businessman in vancouver and at the time
i think he was
worth about half a billion dollars
about 500 million dollars i've had the
privilege to have lunch with him
and just kind of pick his brain a little
bit and want to
learn more about how he does and at the
time he was i think
52 years old 52 years old and
as we were talking and and i was asking
him about
like what lessons he's learned in his
career and and
you know what what is his view about the
gender of the economy and about his
business's vision
and he you got to understand this this
this person this businessman is worth
half a billion dollars
at 52 years old he's done a lot of
different things
and he was so excited all he could talk
about
is his vision what he's gonna build um
the legacy and and he's like it's
incredible although he's 52 years old he
he's as excited as a little kid
and he was sharing with me i will never
forget he was sharing with me his vision
for the next 50 years
50 years he was talking about after he's
gone how he wants
his succession and how he wants to make
sure the company keeps running
um how it's going to donate to charities
uh like the legacy
and its foundations he's gonna support
and all these things and he was
he's just so excited and i was like wow
a
highly successful guy
talking about his vision for the he's 52
years old he's talking about like
a hundred like when he lives until 100
years old or if he passed away what's
gonna happen
and i'll never forget that and that's
the very first thing that i noticed
successful people they think long term
the more successful they are the longer
term that they think
i'll give you a perfect example look at
a someone who
is a homeless person how far do they
think
they probably only focus on the next
meal where
am i going to get my next meal where am
i going to get that
that feel little bit of change an
employee a typical or maybe
someone who works in more like a manual
labor kind of job
right they're thinking about when am i
going to get my check in two weeks
they think as far as two weeks a little
bit better employee people thinking
about monthly
what i'm gonna do you know when am i
gonna get paid how much am i gonna get
paid
they're thinking about what i need to
focus on on a month-to-month
basis right or how do i do enough so i
don't get fired that's not a good
attitude by the way that sure will get
you fired
or a manager of a corporation they think
about
quarterly right what's my quality
quarterly benchmark
what are some of the quota i need to
meet what what's what's
what's the goal what's the objective
right quarterly an entrepreneur a
good entrepreneur might think about a
year
out right in one year what's the
what are my goals what i want to
accomplish in one year so they think
long term
me i think about five years out five to
ten years out
so i would have a ten year plan myself
and then i would like to reverse
engineer
what do i need to do in in in year nine
year eight you're
seven am i on track and then i will
break it down into
monthly goals monthly global goals and
i'll break it down into daily goals
if you read my book f.u money you will
know i believe in the concept of d-i-g
daily income goal rule number five
give something up with grant cardone you
know i've made a lot of sacrifices in my
life
and i'm not asking anybody to feel sorry
for me i'm i do know though that the
first
the first trick to success
is not what you learn
you don't need to buy a course for me if
you want to be successful
some guy i heard some guy saying
cardone's trying to sell a course
okay that's not the first step to
success though
first step is you have to give something
up
you have to give up something about who
you are
you want to solve a problem you got to
give up the idea that you
you've either tried every way possible
or you don't know the
you know that you've already tried that
or that's not going to work or it's not
you got to give something up my whole
life is different today because i
continue to
be willing to give stuff up
in 25 it was drugs i had to get drugs up
you know at 29 it was people some people
in my life i had to give them up i'm
like okay i'll grew these people
they were i love them still love them
today but i had to move on
at 30 i had to move my location i had to
leave where i grew up
and move to another city at 31 i had to
move again i had literally moved
to another city johnny open up your your
your thing over there what were you
feeling
like what was that what was the feeling
that you knew you had to move on
yeah well i was feeling all these times
when i've had to change like gave up the
drugs gave up the location gave up the
friends
i was feeling disappointment in myself i
was feeling bored with myself
i was feeling like anxiety
when am i gonna become somebody
you know when am i gonna when am i gonna
fulfill my potential
and rule number six the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is see challenges as opportunities with
jack ma people like me
i was born in a very poor family i never
got a great education
you know i filled all the examinations
for what reason i don't know
but later i realized i don't have money
i don't have technology i don't have a
lot of good backgrounds we have a rich
uncle or something no the only thing i
compete with my people than
young people is let's compete for 10
years later
this is what i believe 10 years later
will be happening so
everything i do for that girl i know 10
years later
this thing is going to happen so prepare
for that
because i know if i compete with him for
next month no chance
so this is how my message it's up it's a
challenge
but it's opportunity and it's the
opportunity for people like
us this world the most difficult
thing is to convincing a successful
people ah
wait tell him this is a great
opportunity
forget it right i've been doing this for
30 years
but for people like us
we're looking for opportunities in order
to survive
so we will do anything to be creative
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you going to
take
action on it this week when you schedule
in what day what time and what place
you're going to take action you have a
91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan
and when you share your plan publicly
and have some accountability you
increase your chances even further
of actually following through so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
the biggest mistake so many
entrepreneurs make is they jump into a
business because they see that it's a
hot opportunity
you don't love it you don't know much
about it but so many people are talking
about it and it looks like an easy way
to make a lot of money
big mistake don't do that it's the
fastest way to go broke
so warren buffett did not invest in
amazon but he's still done
pretty well for himself he didn't invest
in amazon because he doesn't like tech
he doesn't know it he doesn't love it he
doesn't live in that space and so he
doesn't want to buy those kinds of
companies
and great he missed out on amazon but he
also missed out on all the tech
companies that didn't make it
that he could have put money into that
just would have gone to zero he knows
what he's great at he knows what he
loves and he sticks
in his arena i look at what i'm doing
there's so many opportunities that come
my way that i know nothing about
i have no interest in i don't want to
have interest in that i'm
i'm losing money on right i don't like
real estate
i hate real estate i don't want to i
want to be in it i don't want to learn
about it i don't like real estate
it's not that it's not a good
opportunity it's just not for me it's
boring to me i have zero interest in
real estate
it's great for so many people so many
people have built
amazing wealth and generational wealth
based off of real estate
amazing i'm pumped for you it's just not
the thing that i want to be in
cryptocurrency right people when bitcoin
was taken off everybody was a
cryptocurrency expert i know nothing
about cryptocurrency i've bought
zero cryptocurrency in my life i've been
given zero cryptocurrency in my life
is cryptocurrency the future yep when is
it gonna come
i don't know is it gonna be bitcoin i
don't know i i don't know anything about
the cryptocurrency i get the mechanics
and the general theory and i know that
it's coming
but it's not the opportunity for me cbd
is a big thing now right everybody's
getting the cbd and cbd oils and cbd
products and
great and it's becoming legal here in
canada it already is legal in a bunch of
our provinces and
it's going to be legalized across many
states if not the whole country
awesome it's not me i don't i don't i'm
not into cbd
i don't i don't smoke any marijuana i
never have i'm not interested in it
it may help you it may alleviate your
pain amazingness may be the greatest
gift you've ever seen in your life
amazing but if you're only jumping into
it because you think it's a hot
opportunity
you're gonna lose that being said i'm
also involved in so many things
that are hot opportunities i'm drowning
in opportunities i have too many
opportunities that i know what to do
with let alone don't know what to do
with
looking at youtube youtube right now is
still a massive opportunity there's so
many people
who look at what i've done who look at
what gary have done and grant cardone
and those guys have done and say i want
to do it
youtube is blowing up it's popping it's
exploding if you're a thought leader
if you want to have educational content
youtube is still
a huge opportunity most people who are
the experts
at what they do are not on youtube that
means you can go on even with a little
bit less expertise and go and crush it
because the people who are the best in
the world are doing it they're not doing
it
it's a huge opportunity it's a big white
space still right now
even though i've been on it for 10 years
youtube has evolved a lot over the past
decade and there's still
tons of white space open and available i
need to push the opportunity harder
i look at thought leadership as another
one thought leadership the stuff that
i'm doing the videos like this
the teaching that i've done the
workshops that i've done people want to
be a thought leader
not just an influencer but a thought
leader and i'm at the center
of that trend i'm helping train a lot of
thought leaders people are coming to me
asking me for help
in becoming a thought leader and making
content and being able to do good videos
and be able to get speaking gigs
book deals all of it people want it it's
happening and i'm at the center of that
trend too
league of legends i love league of
legends i've been playing league of
legends
for this is six years this is my sixth
year playing league of legends i played
teemo look i got
i got i got teemo here i got teemo here
i got tristana here i've named my dogs
timon tristana right i play three games
a night on my twitch stream you can come
to my twitch stream twitch.tv
slash believe team come join me i play
there three games a night i'm trying to
get the gold
uh this season which means i'm in the
top 10 of players
uh in north america so that's my it's my
ambition for the year
i watch league of legends every weekend
i have a tsm jersey
let me get it i have a tsm jersey i'm a
fan
i love league of legends i love esports
if you are getting to esports
just because it's a hot opportunity and
you don't love it you're gonna die
you're gonna lose
i look at garyvee as an example and
gary's done an amazing job in hip-hop
an amazing job in hip-hop and he's
brought so many different artists on
from the top of nipsy hustle all the way
down to people were just
breaking in and trying to get their
start he loves hip-hop he loves the
lyrics he loves the culture and so he's
really built a name for himself inside
of hip-hop
he got into twitch a little bit he had a
twitch studio set up
in his office and he started doing a
little bit of gaming but
he's not a gamer he hasn't done gaming
in decades
and so it's not authentic for him and so
he's not going to win there
i love esports i love league of legends
i love gaming
it's part of what i do i can talk to you
about the current roster
for tsm and my thoughts on it i could
talk about the new patch that came out
on league of legends and how teemo is
doing i like it it's just
i i genuinely like it and so i have
these opportunities in front of me
already within youtube within thought
leadership within esports
that that i can take advantage of and
blow up in and i don't need to worry
about
real estate and cryptocurrency and cbd
and all the other
millions of opportunities out there
there's already tons of opportunities
inside the things that you already know
and love the things that you know and
love
there's lots of people who know and love
that thing too
and they're looking for guidance they're
looking for help they need answers
you could be the person who gives them
the answers jumping on some train
because you think it's a hot opportunity
and a chance to make money is the
fastest way that you will lose money
because you don't understand anything
about that
if you don't love esports don't go spend
money on an esports team
you're gonna lose you don't even know
what you're doing inside the things that
you love and
know is a tremendous opportunity and
that's what you need to focus on
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here
below or if you want to learn how the
most successful entrepreneurs think
check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them continue to believe
and i'll see you there